i would trust tom holland with a spoiler
three two one
yeah
we were paired up a lot during the
avengers so i was diving on grenades
left right center
beginning to think now he just does it
so that i can be seen as a babysitter
yes
are we allowed to drink this water by
the way
english tap water is better than
american type water
okay chris hemsworth is the most
handsome superhero in the mcu they're
getting into trouble but i mean
i think
but let's talk about this lizzy
what about the other chris he well
amsword is godly he's a godly man yeah
when i have worked with him very few
times yeah it's hard not to
arm be inappropriate not like that to me
is handsome yeah but it is kind of wild
is that real it's way bigger than my
head
yes
i also have a little head but it's way
bigger than my head it's a huge jump but
he also is charming
and fun and kind a kind and a good actor
there are a few of them i mean also you
know sebastian
yes he's kind of like not being hit with
the ugly stick no um
i don't really want to give mackie too
much air time but he's quite a beautiful
specimen
mackie feels great but you know himself
he does that's what i mean yes i do not
need to inflate that though maggie feels
three inflated yeah that's frog as well
yeah even villains
rolling i mean
don't eat brown is like a good wine
keeps getting better yes absolutely
delicious without you i do agree with
that it does yeah really does he's not a
cooked vintage she's just no
i would trust tom holland with a spoiler
three two one
really
where have you been lizzie
i know that this is a thing yes i know
that this is a thing that that that we
continue this narrative yes
however however if anyone wanted to ask
me anything not on camera yeah it takes
not a half beat for me to share an
entire plot of it without talking about
we're talking about on camera but he
does that a lot yes okay
let him try
he hasn't oh he heard i'm beginning to
think now he just does it so that i can
be seen as a babysitter yes
i'm just making wild noises putting my
hands over his yeah i put my hand over
his mouth and all sorts are there new
characters in this movie
no i didn't know that yeah it's
interesting because he you know it would
we were paired up a lot during the
avengers so i was literally oh my gosh
right of course you were diving on
grenades left right center it's kind of
fun it brightens up the day it makes me
look like a saying or at least better it
than he is and i'm not sure i am it
would be on my own but with him doing it
intentionally no i don't know no i don't
i think possibly he's like right come
and match let's see how quick you got
something and i'm joking of course he's
not i don't think so anyway but um it's
actually really charming sweet isn't
that yeah but then it's like
thinking so he carries a lot of secrets
he's like you know he's more sort of
loaded with the franchise's giveaways
than all of us yeah yeah i have no idea
what i'm ever going to do i find out
like a couple weeks before we get there
in the morning yeah
we actually often did we created
something in the morning we really did
yeah i try try very hard yeah
the only thing that didn't change in the
filming of this film was the title
so true it is so true it's really true
dr strange has the worst facial hair in
the marvel universe three two
i don't know i'm not a big facial hair
guy
i don't know you better take this one
i'm not i don't know i think there's um
other facial hair
that i find um particularly yeah that i
that are sh
that's sharp sharp sharper sharper so
and i think those are but i also i'm
like kind of into his look and so i'm
just going to live in the disagree land
i've got i've got to disagree because my
makeup artist is outside yeah listening
to this oh he would find out and he will
never ever ever ever ever ever forgive
me so i'm gonna just how often how how
have you ever lived with it
like going out well i grew it this time
i grew it for the most part yeah yeah
not these guys but how do you feel about
it in life i mean it's a lot it's not
it's dark obviously so it doesn't it's
not such an assault right on the senses
i mean it's very against pale skin it's
like what it's so dark who do you think
is like worse than yours never will i
ever say that about another character
yeah
horrible facial hair that grows off of
your face that you live with
like
exactly it was your personal choice
rather than something that's in the
comics dr strange has the best costume
in the marvel universe three two one
i mean i am a female
[Music]
it's a
good card
where i strongly agree is how nice it is
to wear compared to a lot of other
costumes which are not so nice no
i agree it's good i also think that
there are some very nice other costumes
because there are talented costumers and
designers all across the spectrum but i
would have to say that i agree this is
like doing a ouija board or something
yeah
i love his cape
the cape is special it's clear
yes the cloak cloak
cloak sorry excuse me
how's scarlet
it depends on what position
i am i need to be in
where
my um hook points for my wires are were
constantly
in
harnesses yeah underneath these costumes
yeah this is true and that's a special
feeling
i'm i'm glad i have a looser fit that's
another honestly this is where i go
because for me pragmatically it is far
less uncomfortable than what most people
have to go through and let alone getting
into iron man jams and all that stuff
like painting your face or something i
mean you know people get up at three
o'clock in the morning on most of these
shows british actors are better at
american accents than american actors at
british you didn't even need to finish
the question i do believe that british
actors are
far better at american accents than
american actors are british accents yeah
i've been i've been ripped into for mine
on occasion but um
if you asked if australians are better
at both i would go really i think in
general yeah the australians have it
down they're brilliant in america
they're brilliant at english i agree
with that yeah
why do you think that that is though i
have a theory
you're going
just the content like consumption when
you live you you consume people consume
american
content constantly but not everyone
watches
yeah yeah um
lots of people do watch downton abbey
apparently
gogglebox isn't on in the states
gogglebox is where you do your accent
work from yeah absolutely
no
but it's a good regional spread it's
it's not it's a bad place to go to but
like i feel like the sounds that come
out of that show
i don't see in british
film i think it's easier to go from
english to america that is from american
to english further back there's just
less tongue movement so it's kind of you
you've got to i'm not going to do what
you're doing right now okay sorry no i'm
always going through it but i mean like
i can't scarlet witch would be doctor
strange in a fight three two one
i mean you know there's no there's no
messing around this this is the
all-powerful
i'm merely tagging along for the ride
[Laughter]
i just i just think she's the strongest
yeah she is she is yeah and i'm fine
with that do you think she's the
strongest avenger i do
i know there are debates online but i do
baseball is more entertaining than
cricket
three two one
yeah i mean
qriket is a okay baseball is baseball
cricket's much more enjoyable than
is that the which one baseball is more
entertaining than crazy whoa
yes but i'm a huge dodgers fan so you
can doesn't make a difference it's not
as fun sport as cricket
i love cricket i like watching the slow
game when i have the time to which has
been you know a rare commodity in recent
years what's happening what's the slow
game what's the fast game i've only
watched a version you have a test match
which is uh it can span anything up to
what five days boys is it what what do
you think yes about five is maximum and
you can have what are you doing
you're watching people try to both stay
in but also score a lot of runs i
wish
between the things that someone showed
like i understand it is on television no
but i mean i wish i wish someone could
explain it to me because you can't just
watch i can't just watch rugby i need
someone to explain to me what's
happening yeah but here's the thing with
innings and halves and it just gets so
complicated with baseball i'm keen to
see it yeah i'm not like i'm not seeing
that because it's not as good as
it's a it's a great game the more you
understand it completely so i feel the
same way about cricket yeah so maybe we
just need to go to an understanding
in the middle yes
cheers
angle american relations are safe
i like american football i just will
never remember dangerous why it's called
football
because they don't use their feet i just
don't understand why it's called
football yeah it should be causally
different maybe throw ball
whatever you want to call it throw it
you don't kick it
you do kick it yeah